what's your favorite number and why
please leave a comment under this video
so i can compare them all and in the
meantime here were the answers given by
some of the top people on youtube now i
had to interview some of these people in
unusual locations like up trees and in
toilets so it's a bit of a hodgepodge
but it's also a bit of fun
i'm derek muller from veritasium and my
favorite number is i
we're the toilets at youtube the square
root of negative one i'm hank green of
scishow and also crash course and
vlogbrothers
and i'm a big fan of
the number two
so my name is steve spangler i am
michael from the channel vsauce i grew
up in a family of professional magicians
my favorite number
is the number
because i love making sevens with this
little guy in the middle so that you
know he's not a one it's something that
my dad always did and i just adopted
without ever thinking about it number 13
has to be my absolute all-time favorite
number hi i'm angela from youtube edu if
you really want to see a real magician's
magic wand it's exactly 13 inches long
my number is seven and i know it's kind
of generic but when i was really young
people told me that it was a lucky
number 17 was also the channel of
nickelodeon in stillwell kansas where i
grew up so then i played a bunch of
sports in every single sport that i
played volleyball tennis whatever it was
my number was seven michael from vsauce
does a little line but you know when i i
went through a phase i went through a
phase where i definitely drew it with a
line um and then i just decided you know
what simpler is better i'm alex from
bite sized and my number is 27. every
year on 7 7 on july 7th i do something
special so i started it on 777
and um i went remember i went kayaking
that day because i'd never been kayaking
before as i was growing up my favorite
number was actually always my brother's
age but when i was 13 i decided that was
silly and so the last one stuck and so
my favorite number has always stuck at
27. oh you do one of those things i do i
do why i don't know i think it kind of
distinguishes it sometimes my
handwriting is terrible and so my sevens
look like ones so i'll toss a little
dash on it
and 17 is also significant for another
reason how come i can't remember it it's
prime what was the other thing this is
called not respecting your favorite
number well enough uh i'm destined my
number is 21.
that it's really hard to explain why uh
my name is michael gagnetta from pbs
idea channel and my number is
24.
hang on why'd you what's with that zero
fill that's a it's a compulsion uh just
from
handwriting so many my handwriting is
really bad i'm caitlin hendrickson work
at youtube my number is 16.
i'm john green of the vlogbrothers and
my favorite number is
because it was the dorm room that i
first lived in when i went to boarding
school growing up i wanted to drive so
16 in the u.s is when you can drive do
you do that with your sevens i do i do
that with my sevens and i do my i do my
ones like this too
all right dude 10 24 10 24. uh
it's a very sort of nice round number in
computing having a degree in computer
science it has a magical quality about
it i guess so actually i also uh have a
little bit of synesthesia so numbers
have colors for me so two is green and
seven is yellow so 27 is actually a very
greenish yellow number you've heard of
synesthesia i don't have it but i think
it's amazing but to me there's certain
sharpnesses for certain numbers my
name's henry i make minute physics
videos and my favorite number is jay
my first kiss wasn't until i was 18. so
it was the last year that i lived last
full year i lived before i knew
uh what lips felt like
and i always wanted to have a sweet 16
birthday party which my parents never
gave me but
but i'll make up for that maybe when i
turn 30 in a couple of years
oh
then the 17th floor is the floor that i
lived on in new york when i lived in
brooklyn but i almost actually lived on
the 16th floor because the building
skipped the 13th right the elevators
went right from 11 to 12 to 14 15 16 17.
boom
he's been with me my whole life
basically so certain numbers are sharper
than others so like a one would be kind
of sharp two is very dull but a three is
very very high this they have the
sharpness to them i don't know what it
is
and so it's like this and if i take
three and seven and multiply them
together i get
21. and for some reason 21 it seems to
be this very bright cheerful
you know proper number so how high will
21 be on the sharpness oh it's way up
here it's like it's off the page i am
patrick jmt and my favorite number or
one of my favorite numbers is
29. now before you say j isn't a number
i mean j is a number i'm cgp gray and my
favorite number is zero
i like zero because it's it's not an
obvious number right you can have
counting systems where there's one thing
two things three things four things but
mathematics existed for a long time
without having a zero as part of it so
it's it's a number but it also isn't
anything in and of itself i'm by heart
you have to tell me what a number is
if i'm going to choose one
all right i'm having trouble with this
similar to the way i is the square root
of negative one but what that actually
means is that i squared is negative one
j
squared is plus one but j is not one but
one of the other things that i like
about zero is that it's the kind of
unsung workhorse of the mathematical
world you have zero and then if you want
to make ten you put a one in front of
that zero and now we have ten things and
people focus on the one but it's really
the zero that is doing all the work to
make that a ten and then the same thing
with right 100 or a hundred thousand
right we keep adding zeros we keep
adding nothing but making the numbers
much much larger students in school are
like oh what's i that's not really a
number and then there's j j is a good
one it's already taken
you know that derrick you can see on
there that derek chose i
you chose jay why what's the difference
why do you pick that one who wants to
pick the pick the team that's going to
win all the time who wants to pick the
new york yankees you know you want to
pick the underdog you want to pick the
you don't want to pick what everyone
else has already gone for
star which is not a number it's like a
number the thing is
it's smaller than all the positive
numbers
and it's larger than all the negative
but it's not zero it gets confused with
zero this is one of those weird things
you get in combinatorial game theory
and
i like it i think the very not
number-ness of it
i think that's what appeals
about a lot of these numbers to us like
the the weirdness of j
the weirdness of i the weirdness of zero
i like zero's non-obviousness and its
incredible usefulness does jay exist
does jay exist
i mean does any number exist
so what are we going to be talking about
today is whether or not numbers exist
and we're going to be thinking about
three different schools of thought on
this don't forget to leave your favorite
number and the reason under the video
and if you're wondering what i'm going
to do with this
well i don't exactly know yet but when i
decide i'll probably let you know via
the number file facebook and twitter so
make sure you're following us on there